cuz anyone ever taken a self-defense
class before okay like 25 women the rest
are dead okay I took a self-defense
class in my 20s and I think we could
maybe update the tactics a little bit
I remember the tactics she told me I
physically can't even execute she was
like if your attacker gets you on the
ground
gouge his eyes out what the fuck I can't
even open a package from Amazon without
getting a paper cut I can hardly get a
straw and a capri-sun so not sure this
tactic is for me none of it was
pragmatic she said to us never get in an
elevator with a man bitch have you ever
had a job never seen an office building
before it's basically a bunch of
elevators full of men if I didn't get an
elevator every time a man was in and I
were just constant look like I was
trying to get into a double dutch game